[Music]
makes sense
one
[Music]
yes
i wish they were like now you have to
pick between these two
we're only doing one of them yeah
left or right a or b and then it turns
into a squid game scenario where it's
like
some people have a really hard waffle
thing to cut out and yeah some have to
only cut out the letters of secret wars
instead of king dynasty yes it's more
letters it's harder i like it welcome
back to new rockstars avengers secret
wars is our next end game so which
marvel heroes will return to fight oh
wait a minute isn't this wookie leaks a
star wars show yes it is but in this
week the comic con news was so huge that
secret wars such a sprawling crossover
event that just for this week the mcu
has mounted an incursion into the wookie
leaks universe i'm eric voss and with me
here to discuss all this is tommy
bechtold yes we secret invaded wookiee
leaks there's been maybe i'm a scrawl
maybe i've been a scroll the whole time
and i've been subversively trying to
turn this into another inside marvel
because i'm jealous i'm jealous of what
you have with mt but
maybe it's just a week off of star wars
it could also be that yeah hey maybe
we'll just start talking about house of
the dragon i mean tommy you were able to
see that early last night so you have
all the details i enjoyed it i'm not
allowed to say anything about it but if
you like game of thrones and i think you
do
let's just say it's a
crisp drawing of a horse if i may draw a
comparison
to a popular game of thrones meme in my
opinion yes
so this week tommy and i are going to
explain what secret wars is how we are
going to get there what the mcu version
will look like and then in the second
half of today's show tommy and i are
going to do a little draft of our top
six marvel heroes to lead our side of
the secret wars conflict on our side of
the no man's land on our side of the
shield aka the living embodiment of uh
the thing of ben grimm uh that uh how
we're gonna who we're gonna
send to talk down ben graham into
lowering those shields so that our
doombots can destroy the other zombies
that none of that makes sense to you yet
don't worry in a couple minutes it all
makes sense yes but uh no one wants
their universe or their incursion point
of their universe uh their section of
battle world to get erased that's not
gonna happen to you it may happen to
your friend look to your left to look to
your right uh someone's losing this peel
down the middle take a bite because
we're going bananas go go bananas we're
going going bananas go go bananas here
in this episode
banana peel peel banana all right tommy
what are we discussing in this episode
eric
i'm gonna cross over i'm gonna incur
right now
what the fat is secret wars
and what the fed will look will the mcu
version of it look like
i will try to find a way to work star
wars into this i promise
there are two areas of secret wars in
the marvel comics one is in the in the
80s there's a 1984 version and the other
one was 2015. the 1984 secret wars was
really marvel comics first company-wide
crossover event it featured a flashy
weirdo in a white suit named the
beyonder who teleports various heroes
and villains to a planet called battle
world to fight each other it was in this
event that comics readers got their
first look of spider-man in a black suit
and this was so popular the marvel
comics came up with a storyline of an
alien symbiote that attaches onto him on
peter's return from battle world and
that is how we got venom so we have
battle world to think and secret wars to
thank for better world uh yeah and this
uh this is so popular that really it
gave marvel comics we should find any
excuse to get these heroes from uh
desperate story lines into into an arena
together um but really it seems like
though the version of the battle world
and secret wars event that they're
bringing into the mcu is john hickman's
run from the 2015 era um i don't think
they're gonna do the beyonder version
but we may be wrong uh it just seems
like that is the more popular storyline
that uh marvel and the russo brothers at
least mentioned from being bigger fans
of now we don't know if the rooster
brothers are going to direct this one it
sounds like kevin according to fighting
they're not uh but we'll find out for
sure at d23 we think
so this 2015 event was the result of
storylines like uh time runs out this is
the era in marvel comics when incursions
were beginning you know black panther
looks up at the sky over wakanda sees a
big red planet looming down and he uh
begrudgingly gathers the illuminati even
though he hates neymar
and this is where reed richards explains
what incursions are it's essentially the
same speech that john krasinski reed
richards gives to doctor strange the
multiverse of madness but without
helpful textbook illustrations of two
worlds coexisting and one getting
incurred uh but during this time victor
von doom and steven strange and molecule
man uh were working against the
beyonders this is a different race in
the 80s dude to try to save the
multiverse or to prevent it from being
destroyed but they fail and so what
happens is earth 616 and earth 1610
collide so at this point up in the
marvel comics people knew the earth 616
universe is where peter parker is
spider-man where most of the events take
place earth 1610 is the ultimate
universe where uh miles morales and
spiderman um both are considered pretty
popular i think in the early 2000s
really 1610 i would say is
what most comics readers were really
enjoying uh but another a number of the
characters from across these different
universes make it on board these light
draft vessels that reed richards is
creating and they arrive all in a
multiversal landscape that's called
battle world and it is made up of
different kingdoms each representing an
incursion point of a different universe
so a battle world is not really a planet
per se it is a multiversal landscape
that is made up of chunks that have been
ripped out of these uh destroyed
universes and kind of uh assembled
together to make this giant kingdom that
has these different sections it's ruled
over by doctor doom who has now become
god emperor doom oh no and carrying out
his will is sheriff strange who oversees
an enforcement force called the
thoracore
and these kingdoms are separated by a
wall called the shield and later we
learn it's a sentient version of ben
grimm and this shield keeps the uh keeps
out the threats of one kingdom that
could destroy all the other kingdoms
like you know keep so the zombies
separate from the ultron bots uh it
keeps separate the alternate reality
version of thanos who's still trying to
acquire the infinity stones really all
the all the most popular characters come
back in some form yeah uh with some
exceptions but battle world's light
source is a sun and later we find out
that that sun is really being powered by
the hematorch johnny storm and he's
being kept there burning alive forever
and ever as a punishment for trying to
turn on god emperor doom uh the moon in
the sky
along with the sun orbit uh you know
battle world the moon is the head of
nowhere
uh secret wars yeah involves a ton of
characters but really at the heart it is
a it's a dr doom story it's a doctor
strange story it's a reed richard story
it's a miles morales story and uh
variants of all these characters and
then a couple others but when you think
of 2015 secret wars those are the people
you think of um now how will the mcu
version of secret wars be different well
for one it looks like kang will likely
be the villain not dr doom the fact that
kang dynasty and secret wars are being
currently scheduled to come out in the
same year to suggest that they're part
of a two-part event the way infinity war
and end game were a two-part event and
that they're gonna both be dealing with
the same villain that's not to say dr
doom's not gonna factor into it in any
way and doctor doom's probably gonna
show up either in phase five or phase
six of the mcu maybe even sooner um but
i i don't think that he is going to lord
over it the way that god emperor doom
did in the 2015 comics
in general when it comes to adaptation
just helps to look at how marvel studios
adapted infinity war and end game from
the infinity gauntlet storyline just to
get a sense of what their cinematic
priorities are whenever they do these
things so infinity gauntlet thanos's
motivation was to impress lady death but
in the movies it was more of a he was
more of an eco-terrorist obsessed with
universal balance so really i would
expect the villain of the story to be
less overtly evil and instead be more
motivated by a sympathetic cause and
tommy what do you think uh kang's reason
for doing this might be
i mean kang is kind of all about like i
mean the the he who remains created the
tva to kind of uh clean things keep
things clean right keep things organized
so i wonder if this is
more of that even though he who remains
has been murdered by sylvie if this is
more of like another kang that's just
trying to
uh
create maybe one perfect timeline maybe
one perfect universe maybe like let me
let me pull in all of the other elements
uh all of the best heroes and villains
best versions and make them fight could
be like who is the supreme strange who
is the supreme wolverine who is the
supreme miles morales like kind of
almost like uh hunger games of variance
is what i would like to see yeah yeah um
to me i think some kind of mixture of
revenge or
um a deal like some kind of handshake
made between reed richards and in kang
prime at the end of kang dynasty so i
made a video earlier this week to kind
of speculate on how quantum media could
set up king dynasty at secret wars and i
think i still think there's very likely
possibility that uh kang dynasty could
uh reach its climax when the combination
of marvel heroes the fantastic four the
lineup of the avengers maybe some of the
x-men are able to
trick the members of the council of
kangs and the kang dynasty into uh
turning on each other and they were able
to play one kang against another kang
until they whittle them down into one
final kang and that final kang prime is
so pissed off that he says well you
can't kill me but i'll make a deal i'll
try to do the same thing to you
and i'll pit you all against each other
in my sandbox
and that's what battle world is as kang
decides he perfectly designs a landscape
to play the avengers and the fantastic
four and the x-men against each other
and against their variants uh and if he
is as successful as uh they are
we're down to like our final champion
representing you know good and evil i
guess in this case uh but like then you
can imagine kang willing to uh lay down
his sword and say okay you properly
defeated me you know like maybe it's
like
they're his scheme versus their scheme
sure whoever scheme was the more
dastardly or the more effective is is
truly the winner because i think that's
kang ultimately you can't kill him i
think people like that you have to like
figure out a way to logically
like it's it's more truly what an
endgame is in chess it's going to be a
chess match right between two different
game boards right or two different sides
of the game board and if you can get
king to like topple his his king and be
willing to accept a checkmate i think
that's what it's going to look like of
course yes i like it so we should also
look at how infinity gauntlet in the
comics the marvel cosmic entities all
get involved you got the living tribunal
and galactus celestials arrows shows up
in the movies they don't go there at all
yeah um so i think the movie version of
secret wars is going to try to keep
things more grounded on the actual
battlefield like battle world might look
something like what you were saying
tommy like a hunger games torture park
as if disney world was fully different
takes on avengers campus and each uh
part of it was trying to kill you and by
the way everyone watching this if you
think disney does not have a plan to
find a way to work battle world into
their parks you are nuts i guarantee you
marvel is doing secret wars is
ultimately an excuse for disney to
expand marvel sections of their parks
that's that's really the game plan yes
commercially speaking absolutely now the
movie version of secret wars as we
mentioned is likely to be a fantastic
four avengers crossover it's gonna be
called avengers secret wars though so it
makes us wonder who will represent the
avengers at this point in history three
years from now with destin daniel
crenton uh directing kang dynasty i
would expect shang chi to play a big
role in the adventures at this point i
think we're going to have either hulk or
she-hulk or both uh we're going to have
a doctor strange and or a wong i think
we're going to have sam wilson captain
america perhaps riggery williams iron
heart we're going to get the new black
panther i think we're going to see
captain marvel and or photon and or
kamala khan i think we're going to see
thor and or hercules and then we'll
probably see some version of the
guardians of the galaxy i think
ultimately they're going to try them all
out over the next couple years and
whoever's the most in demand heroes who
they can also afford to put in this
movie um
i think a question a lot of people are
gonna be asking which spider-man will we
see um i think it's hard for marvel
studios to make these plans around
spider-man because remember sony still
owns the rights to the character and a
lot of people are like well which of
these phase five and phase six slots
will have a spider-man title in it i
don't think marvel's looking at that at
all at this point
spider-man's always been a separate
thing because they have to carve out
these side deals to feature spider-man
so um when kevin feige announced
infinity war again at that point in his
series infinity war part one in part two
that was back in october 2014 when he
announced that this is before marvel
really finalized this deal with sony to
share spider-man but
but feige announcing infinity war really
gave him a lot of leverage because sony
was looking at that uh conference and
they were like [ __ ] you know it's really
gonna help our spider-man to be
linked with that in some way to be to be
part of the party so he we have to get
him an invite to this party and uh
and and think about it it totally paid
off for them because spider-man far from
home was a billion dollar bill and
that's largely because peter had
previously just been in infinity war and
end game leading up to that and before
homecoming he was in civil war and that
was obviously a big part of that story
so i think after d23 in september we're
going to start hearing some industry
goss about marvel and sony back at the
negotiating table about spider-man 4 and
i think that movie is going to feature
both peter parker and miles morales and
i think uh peter parker in this scenario
could be tom holland or it could be
andrew garfield oh wow he might try to
have a non-mcu version of spider-man
just to set up these incursions and
secret wars where both of them can
conjoin again and i think secret wars is
the event where you could feature
multiple spider-man multiple peter
parkers and a miles so i think sony
would really benefit as they're looking
for ways to introduce their miles
morales in live action i think uh
they're gonna really hope that they can
find a way for all of them even if it's
through the multiverse to still find a
way to link it to the mcu and i think
we're gonna have at least a peter parker
in a miles morales in secret wars it's
just too good of a deal for sony to not
include them in these uh events somehow
now we gotta talk about the x-men secret
wars 2015 is not much of an x-men story
because this was still the era of marvel
comics when ike pearl mother didn't
really allow new x-men comics to be
written since fox owned the film rights
cyclops does play a role in secret wars
he merges with the phoenix force uh but
the mcu secret wars i think it's
absolutely an opportunity to bring in
the x-men including deadpool yeah i
think this is exactly the kind of plot
where deadpool would totally fit in and
make a ton of sense to be included um
and i'll leave with the speculation
point of past actors because this is a
multiverse story marvel studios can use
this opportunity to bring back past
actors as cameos uh from robert downey
jr and chris evans from the infinity
saga to actors from the past x-men
franchise like you know james marsden or
hugh jackman or ian mckellen
um i want to ask you tommy what
expectations how many of these past
actors do you think could make it into
secret wars i mean the thing about it is
i never in a million years when infinity
war was announced that i think we were
gonna have i remember that announcement
where they're like the following actors
are scheduled to appear remember it was
like 40 and you're like oh my god yeah i
think it's gonna be twice as big i mean
i don't know you know i know it's hard
to wrangle in but a lot of these
characters need no introduction so it's
like they can show up you know you could
show up with the fox
you know
2001 x-men with like marsden and hugh
jackman and all those guys and everyone
would know who they were you could also
show up with the you know first-class
x-men and i mean i know that they kind
of merge they they apply those are all
in the same universe so maybe you'd have
to kind of pick and choose there but
i
my expectation is that it's going to be
bigger and badder than end game it's
going to be like you know this huge
event that i think the structure of the
secret wars and the battles is what will
organize it and not just make it this
chaotic you know huge
on-screen splash page of like what's
going on and what's sorted out so i
think the fact that we will have you
know whatever the structure of whatever
kang's
or presumably kang's you know
not for life or his gambit or his uh his
uh his his like his
playing board is his
whatever he's got on his chessboard
that'll allow us to kind of
compartmentalize the different
characters so yeah i'm expecting i'm
expecting to be blown away basically i'm
yeah yeah
i think the um
what i'm most excited about for secret
wars is i think it will feel like end
game but with the kind of
risk-taking and reckless abandon that
infinity war had and that act two of
multiverse of madness had yes i think
we're gonna see a lot of characters
killed off yeah and really insane ways
yeah um it's uh i think this is the
story to do it yeah i think it's it
could be a really brutal film yeah and
uh
in some ways like i don't want people to
take this the wrong way i think endgame
was a pretty limited film in scope which
it sounds like an insane thing to say
but like the the time ice could have
gone way crazier the final battle could
have gone way crazier in many ways end
game was bound by this overall objective
to make it a a farewell to iron man to
tony stark and so much of the run time
of that movie was really just about that
yeah it was in some ways bigger than the
conflict against thanos it had to be
like a send-off to the infinity saga and
to robert downey jr's
roles into chris evans contribution like
it had to do all these specific things
and honestly with secret wars i don't
think you need that it can just be like
a terrifying blood fest yeah for for two
and a half hours yeah that just like uh
where marvel is just making concessions
and deciding who's gonna be the future
of this and uh and just really giving
you fireworks yeah and some people might
say that's not as good of a movie as in
game is because we really like the
emotional beats of in game and i agree i
did like the emotional pizza then game i
i don't think end game really needed to
be that different than what it was uh
but i think secret wars
i think uh i want to ask you tommy
two of these avengers movies in the same
year marvel's never done this yeah do
you think they're going to stick to that
i thought my thought in general that
entire
timeline i'm like i bet you a lot of
this stuff is going to get spaced out a
little more i don't i mean it would be
cool for us to have all that content
come out but unless they're gonna film
those movies like lord of the rings
right like basically at the same time
and like you know write it one into
another which of course they could do
i i can't it seems crazy to me that
they're going to come out in the same
year but yeah me too i i think at the
very least secret wars is going to get
delayed to may 2026 yeah um i think
right now they're saying that because i
think they just want to put something on
the schedule yeah that they can aim
towards and who knows maybe they're able
to aim toward it but i think to achieve
the casting lineups that they want to
achieve the vfx that they're going to
need to pull this off they're going to
need some time
and i wouldn't be surprised if they're
like you know what we're pushing it back
or
and or maybe they turn it into a part
one and part two yeah like kang dynasty
already feels like it's part one but it
could be a completely different story
kang dynasty to secret wars secret wars
could be huge enough that you need two
two films to tell it absolutely properly
tommy and i are gonna draft which lineup
of avengers marvel heroes we want on our
side of this uh of this chess board
before we do we want to thank uh better
help for sponsoring this episode many of
our new rockstar staff including tommy
have started using betterhelp and are
using it as a tool to improve their
mental health signing up for better help
takes just a few minutes by answering a
few questions you are on your way to
getting therapy on your terms it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online available to people worldwide you
can log into your account anytime and
send a message to your therapist you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
so that you don't have to be on camera
if you don't want to and getting therapy
every week is as easy as a few clicks on
your laptop or your phone with therapy
it can take a few tries to find the
right fit for you better help makes it
easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available and they have
a special offer for our listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
wookie that's ten percent off your first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
wookie onto the draft yeah so uh there's
just two of us should we do a snake
draft i think so
i think that's fair yes uh
and i'll give you the honor tommy of
going first we're each gonna uh we're
gonna limit it to six even though there
are far more than 12 people who will be
on the board for this we're just i'm
picking the number six because that's
the number of the og avengers yes and
you don't have to include avengers you
don't have to include uh 616 characters
tommy you can include anyone who has
been in a marvel title at any point
whatever pool that kevin feige and sam
raimi could pull for the illuminati in
multiverse madness you're welcome to
pull for your team uh so i'll give you
the first pick then i i humbly pick
a man who can both lead and take care of
business by himself
i choose
thor wow okay
so tommy i'm i'm writing down your uh
yes your thing here just so you have it
explain why you're you're picking thor
for your first pick well i think at the
end of the day he's so powerful and he's
so
you know he's so destructive but he's
also so charismatic that people will
listen and we know people will die for
him so if people have to sacrifice
themselves thor's got that charisma to
get them and also
he can kind of we see now he can pass
along the power to other he can kind of
supercharge thor power
uh his other teammates so i all of those
lead me to believe
uh what a fantastic captain he would be
so we're talking 616 thor the three we
just saw in london yes yes yes got it
got it yeah okay um okay for my first
pick i'm going to pick
uh from universe 1610
miles morales
i'll tell you why uh because while miles
morales may not be the most powerful of
all these characters uh he is most
flexible and he's the most entertaining
i think at the end of the day i love
miles morales i to me if he's not in
secret wars i'm just gonna feel a little
heartbroken yeah so i have to include
miles morales on my team because not
only does he have the powers of
spider-man our man also has you know the
zapping powers he can turn invisible
yeah he's super useful in battle world
yeah good luck good luck getting your
hands wrapped around this guy
morales uh has already got you whipped
up in his web and uh i can't wait for
this guy to join all right uh your pick
again all right uh following miles
morales from 1610 uh i gotta pick um my
girl wanda maximoff from
earth 838.
because
here's what i'll say uh she went through
quite a bit she's one wanda we know is
still alive because we don't know about
616. i assume uh she's burning in hell
somewhere yeah but 8381 and maximoff has
a fascinating story because she is left
in a reality where she is hated she is
going to be hunted at this point after
what uh 616 wanda did to her body so
she's going to be a pretty useful and
experienced warrior on a multiversal
battlefield uh and i and i need more
elizabeth olsen on my team so i figure
miles miles elizabeth olsen uh a good
way to start but the pick is back to you
tom you know i hate to be a home team
you know they call them homers when
they're the announcers that just keep
rooting for their home team
i'm going to stick with 616 steven
strange i'm going to stick with the
strange that figured out a way to
not uh not kill america chavez and and
uh convince her the the the one strange
who ultimately didn't uh corrupt even
himself so
i take six one six strange fair fair
enough fair enough and yeah he's a very
learned guy and what you have great
about him is he's a team player yes
because most other strangers are used to
being sorcerer supremes that's right uh
616 strange had to learn how to like
learn how to bow to wong yeah and
learn how to uh think in terms of the
big picture so i think that's a great
pick and then my my um
my next pick
is going to be
i'm going to say i don't have any proof
that this character is alive only
inferenced by
by john krasinski's uh reed richards
i'm going to pick 838 sue storm
who is a grieving
widow and very powerful
powerful being herself
uh the invisible woman i'm gonna pick a
a motivated uh seeking revenge on your
scarlet witch your your wanda maximoff
uh it's personal
and uh you know i we know how powerful
wanda is but with the help of thor and
and doctor strange i think we can we can
isolate and dispatch of her so a little
gamesmanship on my end here i think a
smart move because her invisibility
matches miles is
invisibility so yeah i think that's a
good pick yeah a really good pick all
right uh it's back to me looking at my
list right now we have uh some some
interesting personalities there but we
don't have any muscle yeah so i'm gonna
have to go with
uh
thanos
but specifically uh the thanos from uh
which universe i want to limit him at a
point in time because i don't want
thanos as all six infinity stones yeah i
like thanos with four out of six
infinity stones okay when he fought in
the battle of titan yeah um in fact i
wouldn't even need any infinity stones i
could take thanos right at here's what
i'll say i'm going to say end game
thanos okay uh whatever timeline
designation that had
when uh when he still had the helmet on
he still had the blade yeah the one who
fought the avengers in the final battle
of endgame uh who came from an alternate
timeline you saw the future from 2014
era whatever you want to call that yeah
um you didn't have the infinity stones
yet because i prefer my thanos without
infinity stones i think he's he's uh he
wants it more yeah you know uh he's he's
less of this kind of like man at the end
of his life who's just like almost a
monk and his mind said no this is like a
genghis khan warrior thanos we know he
can uh beat most of them one on one
he could beat hulk one on one he could
beat thor one on one he didn't need the
infinity stones to do that uh really it
was only i guess
captain marvel and wanda maximoff could
have had him could have had him but i
think overall he's a pretty useful
hand-to-hand combatant with uh and he
has an eternal he's got the strength of
an eternal right uh that's my next pick
uh and then
now i gotta think you know i don't i
have wanda maximoff as a mutant
uh so i like that but i need some i need
some brains i need a thinker
so i'm gonna go with
uh
i'm gonna go with
ultron whoa
your team is so evil or just amoral and
thoughtful yeah
miles morales has so much heart for
everybody he'll keep everyone on the
street narrow miles morales is a sweetie
um so i'm gonna go with ultron i don't
wanna say ultron infinity but i wanna
say the ultron from what if uh before he
uh when he just had the power of the
mind stone okay so ultron plus mine
stone before he acquired every other
stone from thanos from splitting them in
half
ultron plus mine stone all right i like
that
i okay so i got two picks my first pick
is going to be uh from the movie logan
x23 i'm taking good pay
what i like to call an up-and-comer
uh with with not a lot of impulse
control
uh if we need someone to go berserker
she's gonna be our berserker but then i
i also
liked your idea i need another thinker
on the team right now i need another
another i have doctor strange but i need
someone that can kind of i get you a man
that can do both so i'm going to take
x-men 97's beast
i'm gonna take
beast
uh dr henry mccoy both a genius
and an absolute unit uh on the
battlefield oh yeah
and always a full unit oh i love i love
the beast pick i'm kind of kicking
myself for not doing beasts okay i'm
looking at the list here i'm looking at
what i need i have a sorcerer uh
i assume i mean we don't know of 8381
and maximoff has sorcery i think i
assume that her experience working with
the scarlet witch has left her with some
understanding and the way that like
strange was left with the third eye in
his head right so i feel pretty good
about sorcery but just to
just to keep it light and to make sure
we have someone who can help her unlock
her sorcery abilities um i'm gonna go
with
uh
loki
l1130 so this is the loki from uh from
the loki series not the loki who died in
infinity war this is the loki who were
following to me right now the most
fascinating character that i follow
uh i think he's uh that guy can always
slip away from anything he's great at
casting projections he's still got a
little bit of evil in him but his
heart's been broken he knows when to
grasp an invisible dagger and when to
let it lie uh so he is my pick
and then uh i was gonna pick another one
purely for comedic relief but i feel
like loki does that and miles does that
um
so for my final pick
uh i don't need him because i have
ultron
um
i'm gonna go with
just because i love her so much
storm yeah that's a great pick and i'm
gonna go with uh i'm gonna trust the mc
right now and say whatever 616 reboot
they're gonna go with aurora monroe they
uh broke my heart a little bit when they
said michaela cole's playing enaka but i
don't have any problem with her playing
any guy i just think michael cole would
have been amazing and amazing
in the mcu uh and i don't have a problem
with what alexander's ship did in those
later x-men films uh i don't need to see
halle berry come back but i think
there's uh plenty of directions they can
go in with a ramon rowe and i'm trusting
that one of those phase six titles is
going to be a storm mini series yeah
because we need a store mini series um
yesterday so that's my list i got uh or
i'll let you take your phone yes my
final pick uh man was gonna be loki so
you you got loki from me i am going to
i gotta regroup here you know what
i'm gonna go with a heart and soul pick
i'm gonna go with a morality pick and
also a very powerful mutant in her own
right in honor of brandon barrack i'm
gonna go with jubilation lee jubilee
with those plasmoids
and that funky yellow raincoat so are we
talking jubilee from x-men 97 as well
yeah okay great
i love your list i really like your list
i do i like both of our teams i want
them both to live and be friends yeah i
do too and in fairness i gave you the
first pick i probably should have taken
the first pick because i think
now as we went through it i definitely
had the more strategic op and option of
being able to go back to yeah
sometimes sometimes you got to pick from
the heart eric
that's why i never won in fantasy
football because i pick from the heart
every time okay so here are our list
tommy on his uh uh
his secret wars draft he is thor 616
thor from love and thunder we got steven
strange from the end of multiverse of
madness we got sue storm from 838 the
the widow of reed richards in 838 x23
uh laura from specifically from the
logan universe
yes from the live action logan she's
incredible uh and then we have uh hank
mccoy beast from x-men 97
and then we have uh jubilee from x-men
97 pretty good very x-men forward team
yeah you know i was an x-men kid so i
think i i had no i had no choice it was
always and there's nothing wrong with
that you know what they have a lot of
experience in combat the number of
sentinels this group has had to take
down uh the
the uh danger room trials that they have
run together i mean you got a lot of uh
teamwork you got some package deals here
right like this is you really
moneyballed this yeah that's right we
looked at we looked at the advanced
metrics
they get on base they get on base your
team gets on base that's right um okay
so for my team i got uh miles morales
from 1610 i got one of maxima from 838
so this is the one who's uh who's left
over in the in the living room with
their kids
um we got end game thanos uh so this is
thanos from the 2014 era onward the one
who wants to tear the universe to shreds
and start over then i got ultron from
what if when he acquired the mind stone
yes and that here that's which i think
your team would kill everyone else it's
ridiculous your team would just go your
team could just like think my team out
of existence
right i think thanos or i think ultra
would just kill the others to be like i
could do this alone
i don't need anything and then i got
loki from uh from the disney plus series
l130 yeah and then uh storm aurora
monroe kind of an unknown quantity yet
but whatever version of her we'll see in
616. yeah i want her on that team i love
it this was so fun i could do this every
week
we should just keep this going let's see
let's get 24 on each team yeah let's
just finish every week we'll draft
another six it'll be great all right
well which of these teams would you
rather go into bad for you in your uh
section of the battle world uh run by
ghada emperor kang
we'll leave it there though for this
episode thank you so much and uh and
don't worry in the future we will be
doing more star wars content here on
wikileaks that's just a special thing
we're doing this week yeah uh follow me
at ea boss follow tommy at tommy bechdel
follow new rockstars subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching bye
you